before the meeting I'm just going to go
through the fire emergency drills
so there are no planned fire drills so
if the alarm activates please leave the
building in orderly fashion via your
nearest fire exit either through the
main doors of the hall or the store room
adjacent to the stage
the fire assembly point is the island in
front of the main entrance to the
building
please do not delay your evacuation to
collect any belongings
please do not return to the building
until given permission to do so by
Council staff
please note that the meeting will be
audio recorded
please switch off mobile phones or turn
them to silent
the toilets and hand washing facilities
are available in the foyer area
members of the public Weist you are of
course entitled to film or take
photographs during this meeting can I
please emphasize to you that this should
be done without disruption to the
meeting and can only be done from a
designated area in the public seating
can I please therefore ask you to raise
your hand clearly in the air if you wish
to take photographs or film this evening
thank you very much and you absolutely
fine where you're sitting thank you
members there is a need to use
microphones during the meeting when I
invite you to speak please wait until
there's a microphone in front of you
before speaking as microphones are
needed for the hearing Loop and for the
audio recording
these are all switched on and ready for
you to use to speak you do not need to
adjust them as they will be unmuted by
officers when you wish to speak
please make sure that the microphone is
close enough to your mouth before
speaking and speak clearly
members voting will be done on a show of
hands in line with the Constitution
I will ask for show of hands four then
against recommendations and will also
ask for show of hands for those wishing
to abstain from voting
so
the meeting will now start a gender item
one apologies for absence apologies have
been received from Council Lamborn and
councilor Wilson
also councilor Wilkinson have I any
other apologies please members
uh and also councilor shop thank you
Council across
substitute members
um this is agenda item number two
Council Ahoy will be substituting for
Council M bone
and Council across for councilor Sharp
a gender item three non a members 10
non-members attending we have here
present tonight councilor spearing
councilor Williams Council FD councilor
Rowe and councilor Wootton
apologies there councilor Crips didn't
see you
um a gender item four minutes of meeting
held on the 23rd of February and also on
the 1st of March 2023 members are the
minutes approved please
anybody want to agree those minutes or
indicate thank you
gender item five to click sorry to
receive Declarations of Interest are
there any Declarations of Interest
please members
no one's indicating thank you
a gender item six
free three hour parking for blue badge
holders
members counselors and James Newport
John Mason and Adrian is called in the
portfolio holder decision relating to
the free three-hour parking for blue
badge holders uh Council Newport first
of all can I invite you to outline your
reasons for calling in the decision
yeah
thank you chairman
um we called this in
um to scrutinize the due diligence of
the proposed scheme and to look at if
there were indeed any
budgetary implications
thank you councilor Newport
um councilors uh Mason and councilor at
ease would you like to um add anything
to that
thank you councilor Mason yeah thank you
chairman
um I would like to know whether there's
in due diligence whether there's any
data behind the choices that have been
made and the policy put forward
thank you Council series
um I think my main concerns was around
why the decision was on three hours and
as Council Newport has said on the
costings budgetary effect on that
thank you thank you
um can I ask the portfolio holder
counselor sparing and the director for
assets and investment Phoebe Barnes if
they would like to respond to the points
that have been raised
uh thank you chairman I'll start off and
if I need some support Ms Barnes I'm
sure will support me
earlier this year uh Ms Barnes and
myself were approached by a disabled
organization reputable organization
suggesting that perhaps we should review
our parking policy for disabled Parkers
we did this we went through all of the
district councils in Essex and found
that we were one of two
the other being Braintree that were the
only ones that charged
we felt that potentially this was not a
very good PR situation for this Council
and as such looked to address the
situation to put us in line with most of
the or all the other councils except
Braintree
the options facing us were in line with
the majority of other councils who use
three hours free parking or to go to
all-day parking or free parking
indefinitely whichever phrase you want
to to use
it was very close to budget time
having liaised on several occasions over
several months with officers regarding
the financial implications of any
decision like this
we have come to the conclusion it is
almost impossible
to ascertain accurately the financial
implications because people with
disabled parking facilities I.E the blue
badge can park in any of our Bays across
the district
they not only can use their own disabled
Bays but they can pick up anywhere else
as long as they have their blue badge
shine
currently they paid for whatever time
they Park and they are entitled to an
additional free hour at the end of that
our view was we needed to take some
action to make us align with other
councils in the county
that three hours was probably the most
sensible approach to take the financial
implications would be kept to the
minimum
if in the fullness of time
Council feels that that it wants to go
to free parking unlimited free parking
that would I feel be a council decision
because the financial implications will
be substantially greater it would also
create a possible situation whereby
disabled Parkers could go into any Bay
for as long as they like they could go
to London they could do whatever they
like and it would restrict the use of
the parking for other non-disabled
people it would also have a knock-on
effect on the financial implications
that I think with the support of
officers we've done all the due
diligence as far as we are able we have
kept the financial implications to a
minimum and we have in my view put this
Council in line with every other Council
in one way or another across the county
except Braintree thank you chairman
thank you um there's some the officer
Phoebe would you like to add anything to
that
I think over to add you thank you thank
you I'll now go to members for questions
councilman Newport
thank you chairman
um just a few questions so is there any
indication of how many blue badge
holders there are in the district
how many disabled spaces are in Council
Owned Car parks
um because I couldn't find that figure
um what is the availability or the
impact
on disabled spaces now
um Council sparing
I think I just heard you say they can
park in any space Not Just disabled
spaces that is correct providing they're
showing their blue badge okay
um what other options were considered
because there are other options rather
than free parking versus three hour free
parking
um
and I think you've covered the financial
impact
but when considering the financial
Financial impact was a survey considered
of the usage in the carbox of disabled
so you could do a rough calculation
of blue badge holders thanks
can if I had the first crack if you like
uh
we don't know how many disabled people
are coming the number of parking or blue
badges in this district is almost
immaterial
other people from all over the county
can come here and provide them they've
got a blue badge they qualify for the
same conditions as our residents now I
would suggest that in light of should we
say the banking fraternity which is
eminent in this town
disabled people will come to Rayleigh if
they want to go to their Banks or their
building societies and they will park
we've seen the fact that Rayleigh has
stayed fairly vibrant through all the
Doom and Gloom over the last few months
and years people keep coming here to
work out how many disabled people will
come here I think is almost impossible
to work out the finances of how often it
is it effectively means that somebody's
going to have to stand in every car park
counting hour after hour I'm sorry again
it's just not feasible
we have gone down a road where we feel
that we are complying and meeting the
obligations that every other Council
takes
personally I think we have reached a
reasonable compromise
no we can't do a survey on every aspect
of this somewhere along the line
we have to assume that this is the right
course of action it's beneficial for our
disabled residents it meets Us in line
with most of the other councils across
the country accountants across the
county
and you know if District Council wants
to change my view and my policy in years
to come I have no free no problem with
that whatsoever but I think the
implications
financially and by blocking up Bays will
be happily taken into consideration
any other members
um counselor
Miss Mason
thank you chairman
[Music]
did the quest was the question asked of
the councils that are chosen three hours
why they chose three hours and of those
who decided to do all day why they chose
all day
that's amazing no we didn't do that
Council Mason we took an approach that
we felt was going to have the minimum
Financial impact on the council budgets
were just about to be done we felt that
this course of action would produce the
minimum amount of financial impact
uh
we felt that we would then be in line
with most of the other councils in the
county as I've said if in the fullness
of time full Council wants to review
this period and extend it then that I
feel is a council decision because the
financial implications will be
considerably more but having spoken to
officers who have been involved in this
situation of funding and receiving money
in cars in car Parks over many years
they cannot come up with a plan or a
survey that would work out what the
financial implication would be to extend
three hours to free parking for disabled
I have asked that question and they have
no idea how they would do it thank you
could I ask my second question yes the
second question would be and I may have
missed this so excuse me if I have
um was any consultation made with any
disabled bodies and organizations which
support the disabled and what their
opinion was on the suggestion and more
particularly now the implementation that
has been put forward
we we liaise with the the organization
that contacted us initially but as I
keep saying we were close to budget time
we were going in line with the majority
of the other councils in this County
the financial implication was kept to a
minimum if Council
wants to make it longer fine I have
absolutely no problem with that but I
felt that to take this modest step
forward to make sure that we weren't
held up as one of the two councils in
the county that charged disabled this
was the right route to go it was minimum
impact on our finances and we got the in
my view took the council out of a
possible PR situation where everybody
would have played on the fact that we
were charging disabled
thank you uh councilor Mrs Gates damn
hello
well I just like to say that I support
this initiative it's really pleased I'm
really pleased to see that we are
offering free our free parking the
objective of a blue beige is to make
sure there's easy access for people with
disability to use facilities shops Banks
Etc I think the free hour policy does do
this
and it brings us into line with many
other councils I do fear that going to a
full free parking charge
many people that have disabilities do
work or it could cause long-term
blocking of car Parks especially for
those near train stations Etc so I think
this is a really good compromise
thank you
and if we can keep
the problem very quick question you said
it was a list of all the neighboring
councils but the only one that's missing
is Castle point I just wonder what that
was missing but we never got a response
from them counselor we did ask the
question as you can see we've we've got
a response from everybody else but we
never ever got a response from and we've
even asked this week about it and we've
never got a response
thank you um councilor cross
thank you chairman
um how many disabled drivers were asked
whether three-hour three hours was
sufficient or not
we didn't ask any disabled drivers the
decision was based on financial
commitment
I'm pretty sure that if we'd have asked
most disabled drivers they said I would
have said all day I don't know
we tried to put something in place that
we felt was a compromise that would get
us in line with all the other councils
if as I keep saying Council wants to
review this make a bigger survey go down
the road then I feel that should be done
at full Council level this in my view is
an interim step
did you want to come back on that case
thank you chairman um yeah I think an
input from disabled drivers would have
been helpful I think many of them would
have said half an hour or one hour might
be acceptable to them unless you ask you
don't know
I I would suggest that half an hour
would not be acceptable that's my my
feeling we haven't say gone down that
road we were trying to do something that
we could bring in in short term to
ensure that we complied with the rest of
the county effectively
thank you I've forgotten my first
question but hopefully I'll remember it
by the time I get to the end I'm going
to start with equality on diversity
implications I'm quite astonished
that we have found that there will be no
impacts either positive or negative with
this policy I can't see how this has
been done properly this report if we've
come to that conclusion I would without
doing
a report myself or an assessment myself
I would assume there would be some
positive impacts and I think if we'd
done a proper impact assessment as we
should do because that's our policy
as councilor cross state we'd perhaps
have a bit more information about what
disabled drivers might want so I'm quite
astonished that's not being done and I
think the report is flawed just on that
basis
um
on the second point Sorry second Point
South End
free all-day parking with blue badge
that's just for South End residents
um as I have checked this unless it's
changed councilor Newport is shaking his
head because this was their policy
because they used to issue their own
blue pages I understand it so that's
changed that's fine
and the final question
which
I've lost
and as I've lost it that's my fault so
I'll have to um leave it there thank you
um I see no other members in Decatur can
I just come back there chairman um
on on on on councilor Hawaii's comment
I keep saying that this was an interim
in my view this is an interim step
if if
we had not done anything if we'd had
gone through as all the procedures and
contacts and one thing another
our disabled residents and visitors
would be waiting for potentially months
for us to come back with this conclusion
this I believe is the right step we
should have taken we are now in line
with the other councils the majority of
other councils in the county and I
believe that is the right move
um thank you um right I've got a couple
of them yes of course you can counselor
and but this goes back to my original
point I keep asking these questions on
all our reports and I'm getting really
fed up there and I'm sure everyone else
is getting fed up with me asking these
questions if that was the case councilor
sparing surely that should have been in
the equality and diversity implications
part of the report to say that's why we
haven't done one and that we're looking
to do it in the future I mean I think at
the very least we should be doing
thank you
um
councilor sparing you mentioned it this
was seen as a PR reason
um when you mentioned that at the start
that concerned me a little bit talking
about
um some research into how much blue
badge holders use free parking in other
districts I do think you could have
found some comparable measures even if
it was similar like for like numbers of
people within that District who are blue
badge owners so that would have been
quite interesting to actually have fed
into this for the crossings
um you mentioned that this is in line
with the majority of the other councils
in Essex
but that doesn't relate to the table
that is on page 6.4
because there's five district councils
that also do the three hours with blue
badge holders and yet six
offer free all-day parking so we're not
in line with the majority of other
councils just to make that clear
um I couldn't see in the report where it
says that it's an interim
um Step so um that's quite interesting
to know and I don't know how as a
committee we feel that that could be um
well at least minuted that this is an
interim and perhaps asked for it to come
back to the committee
and I think that I am is mine comfort
thank you
um if I may chairman I the the last
Point interim
that's my view on things
as the portfolio holder I have made the
decision that this is the route we
should take at the moment
as I keep saying if full Council wants
to take on all day for free parking and
the financial implications that will
take I believe that is a full Council
decision not a portfolio holder decision
when I say PR I would have suggested I
don't quite know what other phrase I
could have used but if we continued not
and have been made aware as we were by
officers that we were one of two
councilors who were charging I don't
think that would have gone down very
well with most of the councilors sitting
around here they would have been saying
we should be doing something about it
well I did something about it and I took
what I thought was the appropriate step
and as I say if it's my view as an
interim you may want to keep it as three
years or three hours but you may wish to
change it in the fullness of time but I
don't think it would have been
appropriate for me as a portfolio holder
to take on anything more than three
hours thank you
yeah I think it um if I just come back
on those comments I think it's quite
difficult to actually decide whether it
is should be three hours or a whole day
without any actual financial report to
demonstrate the cost to the council
um counselor Mrs Newport
um can you tell me what organization you
spoke with you said you spoke with a
disabled organization
I'll pass that one over to uh his bones
second question do you want me to ask
that now and my second question is how
will you know when the disabled
um parking time starts what what method
are we going to use they're going to
park for three hours but from how are we
going to know what time they parked
there we would suggest that we will put
this out in a press release that they
put it on their blue badge when they
arrive
nine o'clock
should we come back to you yeah
um councilor Mason in the meantime
you've got a question uh no sorry no
I've got a recommendation because I
think we got to a point where I felt
that it was
reasonable to bring recommendations
forward yep thank you Mr Mason uh I I
would like to provide a recommendation
that the overview in scrutiny committee
note the interim decision of the
portfolio holder and ask for a full
report considering other Alternatives
and options to be brought to a full
Council
as soon as possible
um I'm I'm happy to take officers advice
as to what time period should be put on
there
so we've got that recommendation we'll
take the vote on that now I guess
um so we're going to take a vote on that
recommendation from councilor Mason
those in favor
those against
and those abstaining
that motion is carried
Phoebe did you have the answer please
yeah so we was contacted by a Lord Peter
William Brown who was working
um
alongside with South End access group
and Southend Council on their changes to
their disabled Bluebird disabled parking
so we consulted with an organization not
representing our district
it came that that question came to us
which started the conversation around
what as a council and what we do
compared to other authorities what we do
for blue bad holders in our district
thank you council Mrs Newport did you
want to come back on that at all it's
awake can you just clarify so that was
Lord Peter William Brown from Southend
Council was that what you said he's an
individual but he had worked and started
the conversations with Southend Council
and the Live Well group the access group
on how they changed their blue badge
scheme okay and to really consulted and
asked for free he I believe he's a
resident in this area
originally wanted the proposed full day
parking but with the restrict but
working with the portfolio holder from
them Live Well organization yeah yeah
that's that works with the access group
as well okay thank you
thank you are there any more questions
I can see nobody indicating
um so we've made one recommendation
would you like to hear that again and at
all
no looks
yep brilliant wonderful
um so
the rest of the report is just for
noting yes okay thank you very much
members
gender item
seven
brochure District council's volunteer
policy
for this one uh members councilor Mrs
good in Adrian Eves sorry counselor
adrianese and councilor James Newport
have called in the portfolio holder
decision relating to the rupture
District Council volunteer policy
councilor Mrs Gooding can I invite you
to outline your reasons for calling the
decision
good evening chairman yeah volunteers
give up their time keeping our streets
in Open Spaces clear of rubbish for
years with the support of our DC
um the the policy doesn't give Clarity
on how the element of this document will
be working with
volunteers doing such work
regarding the litter picking and so
forth
and in other councils I've noted that
there are fines for people picking
litter up and I think that we need some
clarity on how this policy would work
in Rochester District
thank you um councilories do you have
anything to add to that
yes thank you chair I think one of the
things that I was a little bit concerned
about I read through your report through
twice and it wasn't clear who it was
actually directed at or who would come
under it for instance we've got a
situation where we have the community
grants that are annually awarded to
voluntary groups
Charities that are associated with the
council does it apply to them does it
apply to people who do charity work who
are employed by the council it's it's
quite unclear as to who this actually
applies to so I I think that would be
something that I'd be looking to I want
to raise a recommendation now but
um I'll be looking for a recommendation
on Clarity on that
okay
okay thank you can can I now ask
portfolio holder counselor sparing and
the director for environment Marcus
hotton if they would like to respond to
the points they've been raised thank you
chairman
we as RDC on the environment
area have wanted to put a policy and
have been courage to try and put a
volunteer's policy together for some
while
sadly we haven't had the resources
and in my view this is long overdue and
we have now achieved it
the policy has been uh instigated
following various conversations with
insurers our own HR department our legal
department The Travelers unit we've used
the experience of other councils we've
used our own officers
we're trying to make this very clear we
are not repeat not trying to dissuade
volunteers
but if
we all
forming a support group whatever that be
with the with the name of Rochford
District Council behind it we need to
have a policy we have been told by all
these parties that we must put a policy
in place
if it is a volunteer group that is not
operating under the all species of
Rochford District Council then they will
carry on operating as they do we will
continue to work with them to support
them but if it is something that RDC
instigates
then this is the policy that must be in
place I'll pass over to Mr Hutton now in
case he's got any information
I think I think the clarity I think what
what's her style season we had a couple
of the ex-employees who are quite Keen
to come back and give their time to the
council
um but that you know that's in in almost
a sort of voluntary employed situation
that makes sense so
um wanting to do things such as
um perhaps even meet with contractors
get us quotes go out and do some
inspections for us and and do meaningful
work and practice
um work vehicles to do so so that these
are posts which we we just couldn't let
them loose there has to be some sort of
policy in place we've got to ensure that
um now Council policies are all there
already to underpin that but it just
needs a volunteer policy to refer to so
there's volunteer of policy and
essentially what it says is if you're
going to be working in a sort of
voluntary capacity for the Rockford
Council then the policies of this
Council still apply to you and it's it's
as simple as that and it's more about
again as Council Springs was alluded to
is to ensure that they are covered by
our insurance
as well but it's not to existing work
parties that are they're sort of under
their own steam do not do this does not
apply this is Roger Council side to want
to actually engage someone to do some
work in voluntary capacity with a policy
to do so and it is what it's about it's
an internal problem it does say internal
on there so it applies to Rodger
managers to say if you're going to go
down this route you've got to consider
this first thank you
thank you uh councilor Mill
thank you chairman um
and thanks for that Clarity on that
because we I think many of us were
assuming that uh we're looking at litter
Pickers and things like that
um because there might be some have you
considered though that having some
structure around anyone who does any
kind of volunteering in the community
admittedly they're not in the zones of
being strictly a rotured employee or
even a volunteered one
but we can have a problem where somebody
does something and they don't know how
to pick something up properly and all of
that and do their backing and all the
rest of it because if we regularized
this kind of approach and had a proper
policy across all types of volunteers or
Define them into two groups one is
Corporate the other one's public
and um because at the moment
I think if you were doing something and
then something happened uh it could be
hard luck you know you see where I'm
coming from there this is uh this does
actually have a a good look about the
structure of it I have to say but I'm
just looking at the concerns of
volunteers per se but defining two
groups of and they'll know for the
insurance company would like that either
I mean it's the other side
I think
so so for clarity for example a present
if you had something on the Essex
Wildlife trust and it takes some
voluntary work on um one of their
country Park
um we would still expect to see risk
Assessments in advance anyway or and
even volunteer groups we would provide a
a risk assessment as guidance so there's
still some management of risk there
um and that's just our duty of care so
we'd undertake that anyway this is
really very much about if we wanted to
engage with have actual volunteers were
actually working and answering to
Roxford Council directly then really we
need a policy in place to ensure they're
acting as we'd expect staff to behave
thank you
thank you chairman
um
the concern I've got is around whether
or not
this document is helping replace people
who may be otherwise have been paid to
do the work with volunteers
um I do notice however that all the
pictures on each of the documents do
show people planting trees which might
suggest otherwise and it goes back to
what you were saying just earlier but
what some assurances around that please
uh I can assure you that all the photos
of people planting trees
[Music]
of of volunteers but would have to have
had
as of now would come under our
requirements
but you know we're not trying to let's
make this very clear we are not trying
to dissuade volunteers
we are just trying to ensure that if
anybody is being done working for with
RDC
we and they know what the parameters are
within their work
so if I may come back the question was
out actually
can I have assurances that we're not
replacing roles which would otherwise be
paid with volunteers
for the answers I guess I can give you
that sure something as a council you
know that we we only really fund core
activity anyway really so you know I
wouldn't want to plan uh core activity
with with a resource that you can't be
certain self so you know in that sense
you know the funding cannot be reduced
we're not we're not seeking to use
volunteers to somehow reduce uh the the
base of our resourcing and that wouldn't
be correct but I think if you can build
on that there's some addition then of
course we'll take that but in terms of
um resulting that we we couldn't we
couldn't plan it that way I think
questions if I may
um the first is is to ask in response to
the description of what this policy
might be applied to is to ask whether
there's a program coming forward which
would um you know give shape and real
and real Direction and implementation to
where it would be used these are just
suggestions
and in the second question would be to
say I've heard this
is necessary because of insurance
has has this impacted upon the council's
insurance premium
I think I'll answer the first bit if I
may we have recently engaged a park
ranger
who has proved to be very successful
part of her remit is to encourage
support groups friends of Hockley Woods
friends of Cherry Orchard Country Park
and when this is what we're trying to
ensure that if these groups are
supporting RDC then they will be fully
covered it's not a question as uh as you
as councilor higher said this is not a
question of
volunteers replacing paid staff
we We There is quite a marked difference
in what each party is responsible for
and I'll let you go on for them
um so the answer is no there's no
increase in premium when the idea is
that they are complying with policies as
we'd expect so a paid employee to do so
so that you know there shouldn't be
additional risk so they're inducted in
the same way and expected to follow the
same risk assessments when they're
undertaking tasks
you know and I'm I'm not sure I got an
answer to my question I asked if there
was a program coming forward to
um show us show Council Show members
exactly how this policy will be enabling
in a particular
subjects and areas and focus of
volunteering there's no point in putting
a policy in place and there's no good
members approving it if there isn't
something very positive in its form of a
program to actually see and celebrate
of course so sorry that I can answer
that as well so I mean yes um that there
is something planned there are certain
posts that we look we look to be putting
forward I think again we had
um ex-office him very keen to get
involved so that we post we plan to put
forward so to advertise like these are
ones a volunteer types of people wishing
to engage with and in terms of sort of
schedule of Works work parties again
that's something we plan to be putting
together once this is in place
answer your question
um councilor Mason
yes chairman I just look forward to
seeing a report showing me a program and
showing me
what it's for and to see a follow-up on
the benefit that was obtained thank you
thank you um Council Reeves
thank you I don't think anyone here in
their right mind would say that we don't
need this uh volunteer policy so that's
that's one of the things that needs to
be said first off but I do I go back to
my first point I think actually what
we've got in the document I don't think
it's clear
on who it's actually aimed at and I
think I'd like to make a recommendation
that Clarity is given on who this
actually relates to
although I've heard what you've said
tonight I I thank you for that it's not
reflected in what I've read in the
report thank you
I'm happy to put a sort of it's like a
front page that states a bit more
clearly I think I think if you take it
in the round that it does Hindi it's an
internal policy but I think we can put
something a bit more clear on the front
page I I do take the point thank you
thank you chairman
um I was just uh taking a glance at the
um recruitment of volunteers
and I wondered how this
this part of the policy will apply to
councilor sparing said
friends of Cherry Orchard because within
that I think you did reference them and
said that that this volunteer policy
would apply to that group so within
their group am I right am I going down
so within that within their group
how would this apply if they had
and volunteers who were under 18 because
this policy says persons are required to
be 18 years or over to participate so
would you would the council then say
hang on a minute within your group
you've got under 18s sorry you can't
volunteer for us anymore
and how would
the the DBS checks apply
to these groups would the council then
be saying that their volunteer groups
would be paid for by the council to have
DBS checks
bearing in mind some of these groups can
be very fluid
and how much would that actually end up
costing and how hard is that going to be
to administer
because I think that whereas obviously
we all welcome the safeguarding of
children
in practicalities of that I don't see
how that can be administered very well
by the council unless you're going to
check
who they've got in their group every
time because we could blindly be saying
oh we paid for them to be DBS checked
but that group might have changed on the
next time they volunteer so do worry
about that
aspect we've got DBS checks in there if
we're going to make reference to them we
need to make sure that we can follow
through
as a council our responsibilities to
those that are volunteering and how is
that going to look like you know how are
you going to check because the Buck's
going to end ultimately if they're
signed up to this volunteer policy the
Buck's going to be stopping with us so
I'm very concerned about that aspect
I mean irrespective of the policy that
buck would stop with us anyway if we're
encouraging them to undertake works on
our sites hence a policy gives you more
robust position
so you would expect in those situations
DBS checks will be undertaken I mean you
you would require that is to be
undertaken if you know and and existing
policy would require that to be the case
as well so if you had a group that are
working with miners on our sites then
you'd expect to have the policies in
place to do so
sorry Marcus how are you going to
administer making sure that if you've
got this in black and white it says here
to anyone that's looking at this policy
I know you said it's internal but we all
know sat around this table that we're
expecting these DBS checks to being
taken
how are we going to make sure they have
been taken
and they're current who's going to
administer that
where's who where does the buck stop
with that so if we're engaging someone
in the volunteer capacity to work for us
then we would take undertake those DBS
checks we wouldn't let someone loose
with a work party okay in that situation
and my point about if that that group
whatever group it is the volunteer group
have under 18s in that group
are they allowed to volunteer or are
they not allowed to volunteer do we
exclude the under 18s or the end under
18s allowed to work in that group
where does that it's a bit murky to me
I mean obviously the policy made clear
if you wish but I mean in terms of work
parties then what I'd expect is
obviously under supervision we can take
on under 18s for specific tasks this is
more about wider volunteering so this is
allowing sometimes act as a member of
Staff but under you know you can have
underage scenes under under close
supervision with a suitable adult
and again depending on the risk
assessments as to what tasks they can
undertake hopefully they're Limited in
what they can done to do
add mic sorry could we just have that
clarified within the document that
that's the position that would just help
absolutely more than happy to sort of
put a sort of paragraph on them
thank you councilor Mrs Gooding
actually it was quite similar to what
your counselor Newport has just raised
but what would be the volunteer
management skills and the costs and the
expenses
um and and the recompense do RDC also
have the manpower to actually manage the
volunteers because one Ranger if there's
something going on at Cherry Orchard and
something going on at Hockley is there
the manpower to actually manage this
which really links in with what
councilor Newport was arising
they think
um with the gist I'm hearing is this
this is all very negative as far as I
can hear we are trying to put this
policy in place we will do our utmost to
make sure that it is administered
correctly by our officers
we appreciate there will be additional
work we understand that and we will make
try to outdo our utmost to ensure that
we comply with all the legislation that
is applicable for this Council
firstly to correct your monthly
counselor sparing
um I don't think there is any negativity
here in fact I heard councilor Reeves
complement on the fact that we this
council is now developing a volunteering
scheme I think what we do here here is
that this paper that's been presented to
us
is not as good as we would hope to see
and I will highlight a couple of issues
myself
now um you mentioned that
um previously we have not had the
resources
you've mentioned a ranger as counselor
Mrs Gooden's just highlighted
managing and that is managing volunteers
managing risk assessments managing that
the dbs's own check where applicable
managing the whole organization's
timings the training cannot possibly
fall to one Ranger so if you could one
clarify who else is part of this scheme
um
our officer mentioned that at the moment
is ex-staff returning to help out
um
we've asked for some clarity already in
the program of these volunteering roles
and it would be interesting to see how
these are going to be it mentions a few
websites but how these will be promoted
to the General Public
um again council is sparing you say
you're not trying to dissuade volunteers
but one thing that I've picked up in is
in the guide for volunteers on page
7.16 under recompense
the second sentence says the council
will not provide out-of-pocket expenses
it goes on to stay only in unique
circumstances yet on page three of the
volunteer agreement under expectations
it says the reimbursement of agreed
expenses
so those two statements themselves are
confusing So when you say this
committee is you feel negativity there
is not we just want to be get some
clarity and this point especially
concerns me because it is good practice
to offer expenses out of pocket expenses
to volunteers
if we do not then we are actually
creating a barrier for some people who
would like to volunteer but cannot
afford to volunteer so if you could
answer some questions on why there is
the confusion around the out-of-pocket
expenses
just a couple of other two two more
questions to be answered Cherry Orchard
the friends of Cherry Orchard group
unless anybody wants to correct me that
I'm wrong have their own policies
practices and insurance in place
therefore if we then took over that
group Not only would it be duplication
confusion but also double accounting
in fact we would be looking after them
when they're already looking after
themselves and rather well actually
and lastly DPS checks it would be
interesting to know again this is only
for clarity no negativity about our
Council embracing volunteering but who
would be DBS checked because you need to
be very careful on the roll
and what they are actually doing before
you actually DBS somebody thank you
uh chairman thank you
um a couple of points uh when I said
about the uh Highway Ranger I and our
resources it was the highway Ranger that
was able to because of the additional
resource was able to spend time to put
this report and this volunteer policy
together
when I talk about negativity it's along
the lines that
while I appreciate what counselor Eaves
has said everything else that has been
raised at us is assuming that everything
it seems to me is going to go wrong the
thing is not up and running yet
when we get it up and running and there
will no doubt be as we found in every
other thing little bumps in the road we
will need to address them we're not
being negative that there won't be some
bumps in the road but let's be positive
this is a policy we will do everything
within our power with our officers to
make sure that the policy is enforced
and we do everything to make sure that
both our residents and this council is
doing the right thing and is protected
accordingly our pastor Mr hot in case
you've got anything
thank you
um sorry the um question around uh
Clarity over the out-of-pocket expenses
wasn't covered
thank you so I think just some
experience of out of pocket um
it's to ensure there's some Clan it's
better to have that statement rather
than to say we might pay back it's just
that um I can think of events in the
past with volunteers have gone off and
bought things uh thinking it's a good
idea to do so and then they expect some
recompense from the council or you know
I think of an extreme example was the
higher of a marquee for an event uh you
know and and there was a perfectly good
procurement policy I mean in sense so
these past experiences of working across
other authorities that without the
policy in place at the start to set the
parameters that sometimes people can
still have good intentions for things
that actually we then find very hard to
recompense so it's better to have a I
think a very Firm Stance on this at the
start rather than
um saying we may or may not do so
okay
um
just
say rather than the you try the policy
out and see how it goes if we get things
right from the start and that is all
this committee is recommending something
as simple as out of pocket expenses can
explain exactly what you would pay you
would expect to pay somebody's traveling
expenses by bus to be able to come in
volunteer if they are volunt you're
shaking your head counselor Mrs Gadson
this is good practice from volunteering
England which most volunteer engaging
organizations would follow and one of
them being the very simple fact that if
somebody volunteers with you all day you
would expect to be able to pay for some
refreshments for them or not all
volunteers I volunteer in many levels
and I do not expect if it's offered it's
available I still refuse it but I'm
saying it shouldn't be a poultry thing
many organizations cannot afford to pay
I've litter picked with councilor Julie
goodin I've made my own way there and
I've never expected so I I think it
can't be a condition of volunteering um
councilor Mrs Gadson when we're looking
at making this accessible for anyone to
volunteer we need to be able to offer
out of pocket expenses not all people
can afford to volunteer thank you any
other members
thank you so
we have
two choices for the committee if you've
got any outstanding concerns about the
decision that has been made it can
either be one refer the matter back to
the portfolio holder and should confirm
for the meeting
to record the nature of those concerns
this can also include a recommendation
to the portfolio holder from the
committee or simply refer The Meta
direct to the next full Council also
setting out the nature of the concerns
I think we've raised some concerns for
the portfolio holder to take
um back from this meeting does everybody
agree with
Tim please
um item seven page 7.5 it says that the
existing ad hoc informal Arrangement is
continued I did speak with the Open
Spaces officer and and he he assured me
that there would be no stopping the
existing ad hoc informal Arrangements is
that an either or
[Music]
about that it's about more of a
different level of recruiting thank you
thank you
thank you members
um that's um item seven covered
if you would like to go thank you thank
you very much councilor sparing
thank you
um
agenda item 8 members information
bulletin Freight house and office
accommodation for rupture District
Council staff
the council's director of assets and
investment Phoebe Barnes will introduce
this report
thank you chair
um so this is an information bulletin
from myself as an officer and therefore
is not an update from any member
portfolio holder at the request of
members and the chairman of opening
excuse me committee an information
bulletin was asked to be presented
tonight on where we are regarding the
freight house and office accommodation
from staff
um
so the overview is that we are looking
at options around The Freight House that
is within the asset development program
we
we know as a management team that South
Street offices are not fit for purpose
for staff and staff well-being it
doesn't create
um
opportunity for collaboration with with
staff and departments with each other
there's quite a lot of Silo working and
since coming out of the pandemic it's
been highlighted even more so because
staff are balancing working from home
and coming into the office
where we are with Freight house is that
we are
looking at the options around how we can
convert that into office accommodation
as it has been highlighted as the as the
asset that we want to move out of South
Street unlock the residential
development along South Street and move
staff into a fit for purpose office open
plan office
um at this point in time there's no
decision as yet I can bring forward to
members to make around Freight house or
the South Street move because we're
still working on that information on
Gathering all that data on on Gathering
all the financials on developing a
business plan to then be presented in
front of members to make a decision to
move forward with the options around
what we can deliver
so that's what the information bullets
in kind of concludes on is that that's
the where we are in in this point in
time on freight house and the move from
South Street
thank you Phoebe
um members any questions
uh councilor Mysteries
thank you chair
um
on page 8.2 of the document that we've
been given
um under current situation the third
paragraph with this in mind the council
has currently commissioned a review of
The Freight House
can we ask can we know who that's been
who's been commissioned for that because
obviously with GB still involved in the
background this is a bit of a
contractual concern
yep so we have commissioned a company
handsome Bowen Smith who are have been
commissioned by the council outside of
the contract with GB GB has put has
present has put a proposal forward of
what the council originally wanted
before we went into the pandemic which
was an extension to Freight house and
and a a bigger office space
um would you be aware that we are
working on options of what we can do to
have them conversations of with them
it's we are being very open and
transparent within GP batch even the
contract we have with them the contract
with DB partnership around Freight house
is that they would develop The Freight
House and it wasn't
and the council would fund all that cost
so there's there's no
um profit in for GB in in that
development of The Freight House it was
as part of the whole asset delivery
program it was just part of of the
contract with them so we are just
working with Hampton Smith
as as a company to
look at options of what we can do as a
council to bring them options to the
table with GB
does that answer your question Council
memes
kind of without actually seeing the
contracts I must admit I am a little bit
wary
because it does kind of seem to
uh I don't know it conflicts with things
we've been told before the the depth of
the contract we've got with GB
um obviously they were very involved
with the design
of the uh reworking in The Freight House
now they're not
so you know I I
I
obviously you know the contract better
than I do but it does actually raise a
good deal of concern from the same
councilor Mrs sorry councilor Mrs
Gooding
foreign
Phoebe I didn't quite catch the people
that you said was commissioned by
handsome Baron Smith Hampton
I think it was Hanson Baron Smith is
that correct yeah
did you have a question again
yeah
um so
there are staff that are being asked to
spring clean their desks
in time I'm just wondering where are the
staff expecting to go and how is it
going to be managed if
Freight house isn't currently ready and
awaiting staff and is it actually going
to be fit for purpose at Freight House
with such a limited amount of space
so we are staff to kind of spring clean
the office anyway
whether we was moving or not wonderful
kind of health and safety reasons
there's a lot of documentation that's
starting to build up and that we would
expect staff to keep areas clean and
tidy but yes we've been asking staff to
spring clean to get ready for a move
um out of South Street the option is
that because of Freight House
won't be at a specification that
is fit for purpose for staff as it is
and work will need to be done on that
site
but at the same time we don't want
staffs saying in South Street
in the in the state of South Street is
as well and we are looking at options of
if we can within kind of existing
budgets and resources we're again
working on that business case if we can
move out temporarily to make that
culture change of moving out into a more
open plan office so rented accommodation
we're still within the district
still within Rochford
um
to create that culture change to create
stuff kind of collaborating working
together departments across working
together and supporting each other and
to
begin that step so then from that they
would then move into a fit for purpose
office at Freight House
it does something yes please it does
concern me that we are looking to rent
accommodation again when we've already
spent the past couple of years renting
the school when we have buildings around
that we are disposing of that we are now
looking to rent more accommodation when
staff are already in a situation yes we
accept that it may not be fit for
purpose where they are now but to put
more costs on the public purse just
doesn't make any sense
um councilor Mr Mason
hello oh I'm here now
sorry you're really lucky
um I've got a number of questions if I
may if I put them just you know I won't
throw them all out at once
I was I was alarmed to read that
the South Street
conglomeration of buildings is not fit
for purpose
because that's the first I've I've heard
of that
in any form
when when was that diagnosis
an implication discovered
because the council has been in South
Street
for as at least as long as I can
remember and as long as I've been on the
council
which is now 20 years so I'm just a
little confused as to how a conclusion
does not fit the purpose arises so
suddenly when we have that history
so that's my first question
so
um
you come into this pin and reviewing it
the South Street offices need a
considerable amount of investment in
them comparing South Street offices of
what current staff working to compare to
other authorities within Essex and
their office accommodation
it's comparably
their offices are completely better than
the ones that staff sheet the ones at
South Street
it's like a rabbit woman really there's
there are houses that have been
converted into offices as I said before
there's a lot of Silo working a lot of
departments sit very far from each other
there's risk that actually if someone
was to fall ill within one of them
offices we wouldn't know about it until
someone was to go and visit into their
office so from a working perspective
coming out of the pandemic them offices
would I would say were no longer a fit
for purpose because there's not the
number of Staff in the site anymore
would you like to come back Council
Mason
yes I I would and I've also got other
questions which have pertain to the
update and Bulletin
so
it was okay before the pandemic and it's
not after the pandemic because we now
have a lower density of staff
in the building
and so therefore that has led to not fit
for purpose is that correct I've
understood
not necessarily I would have said the
offices were not fit for purpose a long
time ago but coming into my position
since November I I have made that along
with the support of kind of my my
colleagues that we believe as a
management team that them offices are
not fit for purpose for the organization
anymore but I would suggest that they
wasn't fit for purpose a long time
before that
thank you I regret hugely hearing about
that officially
or in any way for the first time in 20
years so something's gone wrong
somewhere for a long long time
okay so the report helps us understand
that and talks about options for moving
forward
I've I've got to ask
where you spoke of using budget existing
budget
for consultancy I assume and and for
other other purposes in preparing a
report for full Council I hope
to to consider the options
is that what the 4.2 million pounds is
going to be used for
because we allocated that in the budget
and I specifically asked
at the budget what it was for so I'm a
little I'm a little put out to say that
I'm now learning that if that's the case
that there was a reason for it and
should this not have been declared at
that time I feel quite aggrieved
that I've been asking about what's
happening with regard to the ADP and
Freight house for many months and indeed
I've been in contact with yourself
and this is this this has come forward
at almost the last gasp of the municipal
year
I'm I'm quite shocked so question is
money is needed to be spent to prepare
for a report to understand the options
that's coming out the 4.2 million pounds
is it
standing into the 4.2 million is in
with program therefore the
um it would be a revenue budget we would
be expecting to pay any consultancy
support from therefore 4.2 million is
solely for the capital program of
Redevelopment purposes so all the work
doing what we're doing behind the scenes
to bring options for for decision and
building up within business cases would
be coming from an existing Revenue
budget
okay
councilor Reeves hit on a little bit
around GB Partnerships and the various
contracts which the council has already
entered into
clearly
well not clearly
South Street I'm sure
is is recognized and is a subject part
of that contract
now
we've spoken about
the position of The Freight House and
The Freight House Development in that
group of contracts so where do we stand
and what are the implications
upon a change of approach
surrounding
the South Street Properties of which I
understand planning permission has been
obtained
so are there any implications
if we don't go forward with that
contract with regard to the South Street
Properties
with regard to the whole ADP there's a
stop go decision that is needed with the
GB contract and with the GB partnership
any which it needs to come forward so
any decision around that would be part
of the stop growing decision that would
be presented for this purpose I was
asked to give information about an
update on freight house and the move out
of South Street the GB the ADP and the
bigger wider picture of the 80 gb
partnership would be part of a stock go
decision which would come to a future
Council committee
I'm just going to step in there just to
briefly because I'm Mason just to say we
are talking on this report so we do have
to be mindful of that thank you I
thought I was being mindful Jim because
we were talking about South Street being
not fit for purpose
so I was interested in knowing where the
position was on a not that the purpose
conglomeration of buildings that we're
now advised we're going to get a full
review and a report towards the end of
April
so it was important I thought to ask
that question
thank you
um
Council Mr hoy
thank you chairman
um
could I just firstly ask is this a
purely officer LED approach or didn't
have any
members of the administration or
executive being involved in this or
directed it in this way
yeah I'll um I'll answer that question
uh if if that's acceptable
um and I'm just going to be very careful
here because I will remind councilors
that we are in the pre-election
moratorium period and so I just want to
be very clear with members that any
politically motivated questions are not
appropriate this evening
in respect of the paper in front of you
today that's very much an officer update
so there's been a request to officers to
provide a factual update that's what you
have in front of you in terms of the
work that's being undertaken and the
direction given around that offices are
still working to the direction given by
the full Council as part of the
agreement of the asset delivery program
so we are working to that direction the
work that's been undertaken in terms of
reviewing the feasibility and the design
of The Freight House comes as a result
of the fact that we are in a very
different climate now compared to when
the original proposals and Designs were
built with design drawn up for The
Freight House so this is in line with
direction from the full Council and also
us doing our due diligence as offices to
make sure that current proposals are fit
for the current circumstances thank you
chair thank you Emily I understand you
but you can't answer that question
however I will leave it to their I'll
contact you directly on behalf of my
group about that can I ask what other
business cases have been looked at
none or any in relation to both South
Street The Freight House or other
business or other office accommodation
which might be suitable
so
um as I said we're still as many quite
rightly pointed out we are still working
to the direction of the agreed uh
decision of full Council around the ADP
in the business case what we are looking
at is
the options and that business case will
look at us moving out for an interim
period intermediate accommodation what
them costs would look like to remaining
in South Street whilst The Freight House
is developed
um what other options
is there around for us the options could
be endless but we've got to stay within
the remit of what the forecast or
recommendation was until our decision
has been put forward that it is to
change but the options around staff
which is as the chief execs um vision
and responsibility of the culture and
what we want to deliver for staff and
their well-being one of the options is
moving out to Temporary accommodation
um to move back in but Freight house is
still the site at the moment that's
going to be delivered as office
accommodation okay just two more
questions just but just to carry through
on that last Point full Council agreed
The Freight House with an extension not
the phrase house without an extension
I'll just leave that there that's my
view the stop go does it attract any
penalties
um
um I can't
what's that in detail off the top of my
head without covering the kind of the
full contract but if it was a stop to it
what however the contract is written we
would be presenting any penalties as
part of that decision so members would
make the decision known whether there
would be penalties or not to that
decision
okay and at the beginning you mentioned
about
um
options to disable with GB Partnerships
do we consider GB Partnerships viable
given that they haven't filed their
accounts and are overdue
um actually I'm sorry counselor that was
a point made in that isn't speaking on
this report it's referring to a direct
quote made on the presentation of the
report an unanswered to a question
um officers if you don't want to that's
fine
um you can listen to recording later and
then I'll expect an answer separately
then on that but it was a direct quote
yeah sorry counselor Ahoy um
all members know what position we are in
at this time pre-election I think I am
just I type as I hear and it was a quote
yeah thank you
a council across
thank you chairman
um three questions how much is the
review uh costing us from Hanson Baron
and Smith
um when is the review due back or when
do you expect it back
and how much space will remain in The
Freight House going forward for
Community use thank you
I can't answer now exactly how much the
reviews costing I don't have that
information to hand
um with regarding the community space
again we're waiting for options to come
back to us as round proposals of using
the existing space that's already there
if you're a community the hall that is
already there and either sideway options
that could work with as well as other
suggestions for that site we expect to
have information back by the end of this
week for us to review over the next
couple of weeks
um thank you can you um can you
guarantee that the community space will
not reduce
at this moment in time because I don't
have the proposals in front of me I
can't
put a guarantee to that I think uh
counts across that's part of what will
happen with the outcome from that
thank you
um councilor Mrs Newport
thank you uh Phoebe with the if you're
moving out of South Street for an
interim period before moving into The
Freight House how long do you expect
that interim period to be or is that
just an open-ended
however long it takes
any proposal walk forward wouldn't be an
open proposal we'll be bringing before
the proposal of the time like we would
expect staff to move out of where that
would be six months or 12 months and
until we get the information back as to
how long we expect The Freight House to
be developed and that timeline that will
inform a timeline of if we do move out
how long will we expect staff to move
out and then that will come back as a an
update with the report for a decision
thank you
I can't just ask you Phoebe any
decisions to move out into temporary
offices or to move into
The Freight House will be brought to
full Council for our approval
yeah to confirm the Israel Council that
have prove us to come from and um just
for councilor Mason's information the
council have been talking about the
South Street offices now for over two
years
and I believe you've only been back on
the council for a year so you may not
have been aware of some of the
conversations that's been going on
previously to you coming back
exception yeah so that's that sort of
comment
um it's a personal comment it's
unacceptable to me how
I have been on this members
members
members one
um please not now thank you
not now thank you yep in a minute thank
you
councilor Myers
that's okay yep hello
a couple of questions really
um do I understand that the only reason
we're not no one's in The Freight House
in a moment is because of the fire alarm
system needs updating and it's going to
cost about 20 000 pounds
I don't think that's relevant to this is
it it is within the report Freight House
yeah forgive me I have as uh yeah at the
moment Freight House is closed due to
the fire panel is not compliant with
regulations and therefore there's
yeah it's 20 000 minimum in order to
replace it
um
to make you compliant right the next
point you've said that South Street has
got very few people in it at the moment
when it makes more sense in the interim
to bring them together closer together
in small in offices adjacent to each
other
so yeah that is the plan at the moment
we're just going through offices that we
what are smaller than singer that we can
close down to start uh
encouraging staff to work together in
the bigger offices
um but just the culture and history has
created areas that departments see as
theirs um it's not so open plan some of
the connect rooms are but that is the
plan is to start closing it down to stop
you know getting stuff into the bigger
offices
and the last one you probably you may
not be able to answer I don't know would
the cost of rental exceed the cost of
replacing the alarm
how long are you expecting to be out
yeah the the length of time respect to
be out it's not been decided yet until
we get the proposals um around what
options we have on on The Freight House
um our dicks and the cost of their alarm
is a capital investment over a revenue
expense of potentially renting somewhere
um
and I wouldn't compare the cost of
rental to the cost of of the fire the
fire alarm panel because that's about
The Freight House and the rent was about
moving out of of South Street
the only reason not having any clue how
the rent will be for you to 250 000
pounds to rent offices for a year or two
years wouldn't it be cheaper just to
replace the alarm and then work around
it this Freight house is still not an
acceptable standard to them move staff
in even the fire alarm panel in it um
for office space it still would not be
it would you I might as well keep stuff
in South Street
okay thank you
thank you um Council Newport
thank you chairman
um
so as Emily knows um we don't have a
sorry I don't have unrestricted access
to South Street offices so when Phoebe
your definition of not fit for purpose
um that I hear to you say a couple of
times and councilman Mason also was
quite shocked to hear that
um my first question would be because I
think you made issue of um staff members
maybe working in a room on their own if
they had an accident oh dear what's
happened to them obviously that's
concerning
so are we actually compliant with
current health and safety requirements
in South Street
I assume we are and that was just a sort
of um you know a a throwaway comment in
a way of that that example that you gave
but
when you say it's not fair for purpose
does it have Rising damp and mold on the
walls like some of our residence housing
in the district is it that bad
I'd like to know I've not been in there
I can't see it I've not heard staff say
complain about it has there been a staff
survey
our staff are actually saying we can't
work here I don't you know what is the
justification with my last question on
The Freight House closure and the fire
alarm panel
um one of my customers builds fire alarm
panels so I'm quite interested in these
costs um where the quotes are for the
for these costs but what is the loss in
the revenue from having it closed as
well does that outweigh
the cost of a new panel is is that what
you're saying is the revenue that low
that it's just simply not cost effective
to replace the panel if we replace the
panel are you saying that when we
redevelop The Freight House if that
happens that panel would then again have
to be replaced is that what you're
saying so so is that building then going
to become bigger smaller the different
panels needed because
I'm sure that even if you replace the
panel now
it would still be as good for it could
or minor changes could be made to that
system when staff move in so I'm a
little bit confused on where's that
advice come from
yes the cost of replacing the fire panel
outweighs any income we've got from
Freight house since we did open The
Freight House
we had minimal bookings no future
bookings and the bookings that we did
have was for a parish council meeting
which was offered for free based on
based on historic bookings that they've
had in the past and again with the fire
panel because of the age of the building
the way the build is laid out if we were
to put the fire panels in and we it
would need rewiring through the whole
building we've sense with the sensors
and everything therefore any development
we would do which would change the
potentially changing internals we would
need to rewire and reconnect back to the
fire panel so the information I've had
from our asset management team and
surveyors is that
it's not worth replacing the fire panel
now knowing we've got to put a whole new
system in anyway when we develop The
Freight House with regard to the health
and safety of the offices yes we are
compliant our health and safety officer
goes around regularly and checks
everything it is just a a risk and it's
a risk that we have to take on board
with across the organization that we
have offices in in departments that are
that are working from home and working
in the office and that are scattered
around around the building by closing
some of the offices down that's a one
way we're mitigating that risk by
creating more hubs within the bigger
bigger office areas
thinking I've got him one last um member
with questions counselor Mrs Gadson
um mine's more of a proposal
um I'm wondering if it would be possible
because there's new councilors here on
this committee councilors that have
maybe not been in the offices for some
years whether a site visit could be
arranged personally been on the council
now in my third year I was quite shocked
at the lack of privacy in the reception
area if an interview room is taken up
I've seen people put behind a screen
where I could hear conversations going
on when I've been inside and I was quite
shocked at the
I would say rabbit Warren the and I
think today's world there is a certain
standard if you want to
attract quality staff you want to create
a good working environment the building
needs to be fit for purpose and to be
honest I was quite shocked that this is
a house that's been converted and is
long past Itself by date not through
maintenance just through the composition
of the building is not fit for a
modern day Workforce and I actually feel
very sorry for staff if that you have to
go out of one building into the rain
into another if you've got a disabled
person the access isn't brilliant and I
I do feel that it would be really useful
for members to go along and to visit
these buildings
uh thank you have you got a second uh
for your proposal
um seconded by counselor constable
um I think unless I'm wrong most members
would have been to the offices at some
time during their induction
um personally especially haven't been to
the old house I rather
like the environment but then I like old
things
um so
um
can I we have um
[Music]
a vote on cancer gatson's proposal
please
all those in favor
all those against
those abstaining
that proposal is lost
um councilor Mrs goodim
and I believe you are the last um speak
on this item thank you chair given all
the information that we've heard so far
and the outstanding business development
case which is due to come in April and
the financial impact that this will have
through the changes being made I wish to
propose a motion that this meeting be
deferred and heard at the first overview
and scrutiny meeting after the elections
to include a full report which includes
the business development the staff plan
the budget relating to the case and how
it will be managed
and just just to clarify um council Mrs
Gooden
um I think you mean this item not this
meeting to be deferred
um it is coming to full Council
I'm not sure of that date
so are you proposing a motion that we
review it
in its entirety before it goes to full
Council
yes please because she wants to right
have you got um
yeah
um Emily
thank you chair um I just wanted to
offer some advice and because
essentially what you would be doing is
deferring a piece of information
um so I'm not sure that Mrs Goodings
council Mrs Goodings
um motion Stacks up I would advise the
committee that as Miss Barnes has
previously said before any decision is
taken
um that will come to full Council full
Council will be the decision maker that
decision report supporting that decision
will include the items that you've just
mentioned so things like the Staffing
Arrangements the budget the options etc
etc so I I feel that I understand the
the purpose of your suggestion but I
don't think it's necessary in the
governance Arrangements because it's
taken care of anyway and in terms of
that timing obviously we would hope to
bring that as soon as we possibly can
within the new Municipal year bearing in
mind the uh the calendar of meetings
that's already been agreed and so we'll
look to do that at the earliest
opportunity once we have all the
information and once we can fit that
into the schedule thank you
um
council Mrs good and would you like to
given that information I'll withdraw my
deferral thank you
and there are no other
members indicating to ask any questions
so thank you members I think we've
debated item well moving on to a gender
item number nine the key decisions
documents
so if I go through them Page by a page
nobody requires me to read them out and
their entirety do they
so um
the actual key decisions start on page
two so page two has anybody got any
questions please indicate councilor Mr
hoye
good idea it's getting late um
Lisa hold which Pavilion
um
could ask the officers to approach me
because I've been approached many times
by people who want to lease or would
like to use the Pavilion so if you if
you go through local councilors you may
get some help I had been approached by
councilor sparing about a third party
which was interested in
The Pavilion possibly for a gym I've
actually spoken to that party and
understand it's too small for them I
don't know if you've heard back from
that yeah
that was that page thank you
thank you um page three
anybody indicate
and then where we'll move on to our
final item of the evening item 10 the
work plan
you have in front of you the work plan
that we have gone through for this year
um if I can refer members to turn to
page 10.4 it has items to be scheduled
in 2023-24
one thing I would like to propose as it
has been brought forward many times is
that the first of the six monthly
updates on the cost of living comes to
the first
overview and scrutiny meeting of the new
Municipal year do I have a second year
for that
councilor Mr Mason all those in favor
and that motion's carried thank you very
much members has anybody any other
questions on
item 10
uh Council Ahoy
this may be presumptive given what's
that there is a potential meetings for a
night
but regardless of that meeting I would
like to put on the future work plan a
constructive review of the process
around the summons to the development
control committee of the 28th of
February 2023
I think it's that simple yes thank you
do I have a second for that please
yes of course yep a constructive review
of the process around the summons to the
development control committee of the
28th of February 2023
um could you use your mic please
thank you I thought that was coming
before forecast tomorrow I think you're
actually thinking
PNC
um our monitoring officers just going to
speak uh German I'd want to take out
away and have a look and see what
authority of the opening scrutiny
committee has uh to do that I'm not
saying no but I just want to be
absolutely clear on that bearing on the
uh the advice that we've received
recently and the fact that there is a
meeting tomorrow as well
um
councilor Hoy did you want to come back
on that before
I personally don't see why we can't have
a review ourselves of the process in
relation to our constitution how that
worked and to just to learn lessons from
it there was confusion amongst members
and at the very least it would be good
to clear that up with a review I I I
would gladly second that and I think
Others May but our monitoring officer
would like to speak
German I just want to be absolutely
clear but that's all I hear what it was
saying um you know and I just want to be
absolutely clear what that was is within
the uh but the uh parole of the scrutiny
committee and that it can't happen I'm
not looking to stop it I just want to be
clear
um
I I will inject his chair here councilor
Hoy I noticed the review of The
Constitution is actually on our work
plan would you like to bring that
forward to early in the year
yes I think that would be the case
anyway so um is everybody happy with
that we bring forward the review of The
Constitution early in the new Municipal
year on the work plan
uh councilor Mason just one question I
mean obviously
um it depends on the progress that
officers and members are able to make
with regard to that piece of work on the
review of The Constitution
um could could we ask visual to to
comment as whether you know early in the
municipal year is possible
thank you chair
um obviously we're all desperate to take
that question councilor Mason
um so so as you can imagine any review
of The Constitution is a complex and
lengthy activity we have already started
that activity with a cross-party working
group and some areas have already been
identified for review I am sure that we
could bring an item to overview and
scrutiny committee early in the new
Municipal year indicating what changes
have already been identified that are
necessary for the Constitution and
enabling a discussion at this committee
about other items that you'd like to see
addressed in that review thank you chair
thank you Emily I think that sounds
absolutely agreeable to all members
you know me
not agreeing good
um so that brings the
um evening to
um an end thank you members for your
time tonight thank you
why I'm here